STAFF, THEY START THE GAME UP
AGAINST TH
STRENGTHS.
PLAY TO INJURERITY HERE BY THE
OFFICIALS.
LOOK AT THAT RIGIGGHING.
SO THE TEAM SKATE FOURU DON'T W.
VERY FEW TEAMS IN THE NATIONAL
HUBERDEAU.
KICKED OUT BY  CHANCE TO WALK R
INULL
STRENGTH.
STICK SAVE.
MADE B KUZNETSOV.
FORSLING AND HUBERDEAU.
STRAIGHT AWAY.
SCHULTZ.
HERE'S MANTHA.SCORE!
DEFLECTED IN FRONT.
T.UCK GETS PAST AARON
EKBLAD.
NOW IT'S A MAD SCRAMBLE.
HE RIGH.
SLIDES IT ACROSSE BEING AN
ADVANCE FOR ..
0-10 IN THE SERIES
PAD THERE.
AND FEHERVARY IS NOT ABLE TO
AM.
.
KUZNETSOV MOVES IN AND SCORES!
BURIES IT UP TOP.
RIGHT THERE. BENNETT.
3:I IMAGINE HE'S A VERY AGGRESS.
3:09 LEFT.
AND HERE'S THE OPPORTUNITY ICE
FLORIDA WITH 3:09 ON THE.
>> Bryce: THAT HIT THE SIDE OF
THE NET.
THAT'S PROBABLY WHY IT WAS AN
ICING CALL. SCORE.
WITH THE EXTRA SKATER ON THE
ICE.T THE PUCK RETREET BOBROVSK.
YOU'D BETTER MAK
WINS GAME FOUR IN OVERTIME FOR
THE FLORIDA PANTHERS